on va retrouver tout de suite m'a dit
ibrahim kanté enseignant chercheur à
l'université des sciences juridiques et
politiques de de bamako bonjour merci
merci d'être à nos côtés on vient
évoquer c'est ce souci dans la
rhétorique ne pas évoquer le mot retrait
départ plutôt privilégier le mot
redéploiement sauf que dans les faits
les les bases vont bien fermer d'ici
quatre à six mois en tout cas c'est
l'échéance est annoncée dévoilée par
emmanuel macron tout à l'heure
merci pour l'invitation et bonjour à
tout le monde
et ce soit au niveau de la population
malienne ou au niveau des autorités
viennent c'est pas une soupe est en
train de vie à camara s'était déjà dans
la tête au niveau du mali que ce soit la
population d'ottawa où que ce soit
l'autorité qu'on voit aujourd'hui il y
aura une déclaration qui va être
vraiment sûr de rester a déclaré de
retrait des fois quand ainsi que
l'apport s'offrent européenne temps ou
pas du man alors ce qui est important
c'est un point de signer ça c'est que le
premier point de signaler ce qui est le
président en remarquant a dit clairement
qu'ils vont rester en afrique
précisément le sahel pour lutter contre
le terrorisme notamment de les
positionner leurs différences forces
européennes même si sa santé le lui aux
mines base militaire qui va être
installé pour essayer décidé de diffuser
la population mais plutôt de venir avec
le soutien aux états locaux aux forces
locales de chaque pays qui décident de
demander d'avoir un soutien au niveau de
la france aux dépens des lions africains
et nous tous points qui est important
aussi de signaler des c 17 décès
disposera c'est l'implication de la
population locale dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme je suis un chercheur qui a
fait parce que le cfpj sa haine du
kabyle en mauritanie alors on regarde
tous mais ceux qui étaient sur le
terrain c'était de lutter contre le
terrorisme
sur la base des deux militaires essaient
d'éviter militairement à l'occ et par
rapport la ligue 2 entre le terrorisme
qui est un phénomène
asymétrique c'est difficile de
comprendre qu'on sait l'homme avec
l'implication de la population locale
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme je
pense bien ça sera un point important
qui peut être une solution pour la
sécurité actuellement pour le terrorisme
dans le sahel notamment dans la région
les torontois ont du mal à digérer pina
faso alors je pense bien c'est pas un
nouveau bain je suis sûr qu'ils aient
aussi au niveau du du mali l'autorité
face au mali n'est pas un pays peut être
aidé ou d'isoler
de l'existence au niveau du sahel ou au
niveau de la terrasse à l'autorité va
continuer à négocier avec avec la cedeao
avec la l'union africaine pour trouver
une sortie qui est de réorganiser encore
l'élection présidentielle pour avoir un
président
à tous les maliens qui nous écoutent et
qui ont un probablement suivi cette
intervention du chef de l'état français
y avait peu de doute un évidement sur
sur cette annonce faite aujourd'hui
qu'elle est quel est l'état d'esprit
vis-à-vis de ce alors on va pas dire
départ redéploiement
hockey écouté par rapport au niveau du
mali quand même je pense au niveau de la
population parce qu'il y avait une
partie de la population qui demandait
déjà le départ
déjà ko quand je faisais des enquêtes
sur le terrain pour quémander la
population sur le morceau qui étaient
sur le terrain c'était de montrer qu'on
point de ces forces là n'ont pas donné
vraiment le résultat
souhaité par la population j'ai passé
des mois maintenant et il y aura encore
une autre et de plasma dans le pays
voisins comme le président maintenant à
portée mais qui sera normalement dans le
dans la région frontalière du mali et le
niger alors je pense bien le malien ils
vont commencer avec des chiens est-ce
qu'ils vont apporter des résultats au
moins déjà vu le cas du niger
qu'est-ce-qui que j'avais une fois 10
partie de la culture qui s'opposaient il
est ko au passage seulement deux forces
françaises qui vous qui partez du
burkina faso de la côte hiver vers le
mali voilà je pense bien ça sert à une
autre débat sur le
bris et obama aujourd'hui
concernant leurs déplacements ad c'est
différent pour sa 20 autres pays de la
région vraiment dégoûté sera des
flamands